Hello,
you are in this,
this position now with this film coming out to help a lot of people.
I think this film is not just going to tell your story and in an open up a lot
of people's eyes as to,
I hope so.
The AOL situation on it,
but I think a lot of people,
you know,
you're such a powerful guy that I'm it from them.
Joe,
I'm sure you are.
And,
and,
and you know,
and they didn't know how to find me or they will find me and I'll do what I can.
Um,
some I give everybody as much of a chance as I can.
there's a line of what's sold to abuse survivors that I think is horse shit and
that's basically they get quote unquote empowered.
And I hate that word because it takes the strength of the word power.
What's what sounds more like power power or empowered empires like sandy making
wear birkenstocks or something,
you know,
so,
so I'm not that big on empowered,
but they,
like I did a,
my friend Sam,
there's a podcast a couple weeks back and he said,
I don't want to give away with the movies.
I said,
listen man,
it's not that kind of movie.
And it hinges largely on the fact that I survived raped as a child.
Well,
I got,
I heard from several people said,
you know,
you really should have had a trigger warning on there.
And it's like,
what the fuck do you shake?
I was doing what the fuck do you think I was doing when I said it hinges largely
I was warning you that what it was about right there,
but someone has empowered you to,
to have a way to take issue with me because I'm not completely basing I,
you know,
the whole world isn't based around me.
Even though I got raped when I was four years old.
Everybody shouldn't be thinking in terms of that all the time because they'd
been through their own shit and they're dealing with their own shit and they're
trying to survive.
So if I could make them more sensitive to this issue,
if I can show them that it matters to them that they deal with other people who
have been through this kind of trauma and we want to reduce it as much as
absolutely possible.
That's good.
But after that,
if I'm going to find a way to set up a situation where I'm always the injured
party and that prove again and again that I'm persecuted and no one's thinking
in terms of me that I'm never going to get fucking healed.
I'm never going to get fucking healed.
So one I did was I went out and I try to help other people.
When I help other people.
I realized how far along I've come and I realized there's really something in it
for me to do that.
And it's not like I'm this altruistic guy.
It's like I'm saving my own life.
And you know,
like that aol investigation that took such courage to do it,
know what would have taken courage was turning my back on those kids and walking
away going like,
oh,
I don't want to know what's going on in there.
I.
How would I live with that guy?
How would I live with myself then?
But they,
you know,
like I is nice.
Everyone said,
Oh gee,
that what he went through when he was doing that investigation.
What about the kids in the fucking pictures?
That's what I want everyone to know about.
Thanks for caring me,
but it's the kids in the pictures I give a shit about.
It's the kids that are suffering right now somewhere within the sound of my
voice.
Someone in this broadcast like where this is on,
someone in the next apartment or wherever some kid is going through this shit,
have the courage to know about it.
That's all I asked.
You have the courage to know about it and save the contemporary children so you
don't have to deal with a bunch of fucking maniac abuse survivors up and anybody
can diffuse the term soundscape.
Guys coming in now,
if anybody can diffuse the term trigger warning,
you're the fucking guy.
Jesus.
God Damn Christ,
stop [inaudible].
We're going to develop a nation of permanent children.
Like if anybody can tell their story and doesn't need a fucking trigger warning,
it's you in this.
This idea.
I don't.
I don't need trigger warnings.
If you're going to show me something,
show me something and if I don't want to see it,
let me know what it is before you show me,
tell me what the.
The,
the documentary was about.
No need a goddamn triggered.
This fucking term is disgusting.
It's a disgusting tournament.
Does damage.
It just sets people up to stay in the pit,
you know,
to wallow.
It's empowering them to wallow like we'll I've got hurt again because the whole
society,
it's like,
sorry about that shit man,
but I'm telling you what,
I know you're in a pit of your own shit.
I know you're used to the temperature and the smell of it doesn't mean you're
used to that and it doesn't bother you that much anymore,
but when you stand up and they fucking hose you off and then you'd go in the
house and take a real shower and put on some clean clothes,
you're not going to believe how much better you feel,
so stop letting other people tell you that you have to expect the world to do
the impossible and that's be the like telepathic about what the fuck you've been
through.
Get to the point where you can stand up and tell them the story yourself when
it's appropriate and don't put up with anybody who is truly being insensitive or
snickering about any of this shit.
Fuck.
People who tell me,
people walk up to me all the time and tell me like,
well,
you know,
the good thing is those guys get arrested.
I am Bobo like you're endorsing rape to me.
You're fucking endorsing rape to me,
motherfucker.
I don't want anyone raped,
ever.
Not even rapist.
Rape is illegal.
How about making jails lawful places?
How about that?
For an idea,
how about someone going to jail and realizing the law protects me sometime I'm
not going to be raped,
I'm not going to be menaced here.
I'm going to admit and maybe dale will start thinking about getting reformed,
but Jesus Christ don't joke to me about right.
Don't tell me you want them all killed and sweep them under that rug because I
was born without blood on my hands.
I don't want to fucking blood on my hands now man,
so don't guess these stupid ass fucking lightweight things and presume I'm going
to sign off on them because I don't ever want anyone else ever raped and if it
happens,
even if it's elbow rapist,
I'm opposed to it and I don't want them fucking killed either.
Now I want them to live with what they did.
Now this is a difficult.
This is difficult thought and it's a difficult subject,
but did you,
after this is all said and done,
are horrendous moment in your life,
many moments in your life.
Did you try to figure out what would create a person like the guy who did that
to you?
Did you try how much time?
Yeah,
and I can tell you what created him.
He was taken out of an abusive home.
He was put into foster care and abused many more times and he was gone and he
was gone.
He was gone and he was succumbed by the agony I was put through by him.
I survived.
Somehow I made it so call me lucky.
I'm not.
I didn't become him.
I didn't become what I resisted.
I didn't,
I didn't pass along the poison.
Maybe I didn't in some ways when I was difficult or whatever,
but mostly I didn't.
Mostly when I'm mad I'm mad because it's like Hendrick's a cry of love.
It's a cry of love that I make.
It's a cry of love.
My Act has been a cry of Levis.
Like I don't want the innocent hurt anymore.
I don't want people victimized because of greed and cowardice and bullshit,
you know,
I don't want that and so I,
I do what I can to stand up to it.
To.
Were there moments where you wanted to talk to him?
What do you want to talk to them?
I would love to talk to him to show him that I didn't become a monster like he
was.
I W I would have.
I would have almost become an advocate for him in the sense that like,
well,
maybe let me know if they're mistreating you in here,
but he died in prison.
No one claimed his body and I don't know where his grave is.
If I knew her as grave as I go,
put fucking flowers,
not for him.
For me,
the idea that someone could do that after someone did that to them seems
insanely counterintuitive.
It's like if someone's.
The only thing that saves you but really saves you really is redemptive in
really saves you to me
was one of the things that you covered in the film that I thought was really a
very powerful moment where you talked about this thing that you didn't become
him,
that you maybe if your sister didn't come down there and Kevin Den,
you could have been dead.
It was close,
man.
It was closed,
but do you also that you could have been one of them?
You could have been someone who would.
Would be worse than death.
Yeah.
I'd rather be a victim of thousand times on the perpetrator wants and that's not
any bull shoe.
Contemplate the mechanism.
Did you try,
have you tried to understand the mechanism that turns an abused person into an
abuser?
What?
What is that?
I don't.
I don't think I'm as nuts and bolts because I listened to you and I know how
much like how,
what detail you go into.
So I understand how,
how on what you're asking,
but I can't be.
There's enough of me that's been through enough that I can't be quite as
thorough as you're asking me to be.
To answer that.
I get as close as I can and I understand what happened.
But then after point I,
I can't.
I'm not one of them and I can't go far enough to say,
well then of course if you get past this point right here,
then obviously this is that I can't do that.
It's that,
that is what is too much for me.
You know,
one of the reasons I was interested in making the movie was when,
when Barry,
you know,
told me that the guy had died in prison.
I said,
how that make you feel,
and he,
he said it made me sad and I said,
because you didn't get any closure,
you know,
you didn't get to confront him.
And he said,
no,
he died alone.
And um,
I was really blown away by that and I thought
I should really make a movie about this.
Now.
I thought that I thought,
well,
this is like,
you know,
this is Jesus stuff,
and that's what this is.
And whipping on the water.
So,
so,
you know,
that was,
that really did motivate me to make the movie,
you know.